Hi everyone! I'm Lang Lang and I was born in China.
My first music experience was watching cartoons...
...and one of my favorite characters was Tom the cat.
Tom and Jerry but I've always liked Tom a little bit more...
...because he's more silly so, somehow he's better.
I started to play piano at the age of three.
My first teacher was my father but he was not very good.
After a year, I actually demanded to change to a better teacher.
So when I was four, I started to really study, like kind of professionally.
I practiced two hours a day or three hours.
I made my first recital right after winning my first competition at the age of five.
That recital really made me have a, kind of a dream...
...to become a pianist...
...because I thought being on stage feels pretty amazingly natural...
...and I feel very satisfied and I really love to share music to the audience.